this is a painting of us general
winfield scott entering mexico city on
september 15 1847. scott landed with a
u.s naval fleet several weeks beforehand
he bombarded the coastal stronghold of
veracruz and then fought his way inland
toward the capital scott actually
followed the same route that spanish
conquistador hernan cortez took more
than 300 years earlier winfield scott's
campaign to mexico city was just one of
three fronts in the two-year-long
continent-spanning effort of the united
states to take mexican territory by
force the other two fronts were in
california and new mexico after the two
nations made peace by signing the treaty
of guadalupe hidalgo in mid-1848 the
united states gained over a million
square miles of new territory a landmass
larger than the louisiana purchase for
mexico this war was a catastrophic
defeat which resulted in the loss of
about one-third of its total area the
mexican-american war doesn't really loom
large in american memory compared to the
revolutionary war or the civil war but
it was a transformative event in the
history of the united states and north
america on the scale of national
politics the war led to political
realignment and eventually the civil war
but on a human scale it led to
transformations in the lives of people
who lived in the west who went to bed
one day in mexico and woke up the next
day in the united states national
boundaries shifted under their feet for
those people the outcome of the war
meant new laws
customs new friends and enemies and even
the loss of rights and privileges so
let's dive a little deeper into the
causes and effects of the
mexican-american war the war began in
april of 1846 a mexican cavalry brigade
attacked u.s forces who were under the
command of general zachary taylor across
the rio grande river from the town of
matamoros mexico after this attack
president james k polk sent a war
message to congress he fumed that the
mexican troops had invaded our territory
and shed american blood on the american
soil now back up a minute you may be
wondering as many keen observers did at
the time what exactly were us forces
doing there near the rio grande river in
the first place and the answer to that
reveals the two major causes of the war
texas annexation and manifest destiny
let's start by talking about texas
annexation american settlers many of
whom were slave owners had been moving
to texas since the 1820s when the region
was still controlled by spain after
mexican independence the country
outlawed slavery but the american
settlers resisted the mexican
government's authority in 1836 they
rebelled and won independence for texas
they requested that the united states
annexed the new nation shortly
thereafter but adding another slave
state to the union was politically
dangerous for the administration at that
time so texas remained an independent
nation until
1845. in 1845 democratic president james
k polk took office now polk was an
ardent expansionist he was a believer in
manifest destiny this idea that god
wanted the united states to expand
across the north american continent polk
wanted to annex texas which his
administration undertook immediately he
also desperately wanted california which
was a hub of commerce on the pacific
ocean this is actually before gold was
discovered there so polk sent a
representative to the mexican government
offering to buy california but mexico
said california was not for sale polk
was determined to get this territory
with blood or money so he came up with
an alternate plan the border between
mexico and texas was under dispute so
polk directed general zachary taylor to
go down into this disputed territory and
provoke hostilities and that's exactly
what happened when the mexican cavalry
attacked taylor's forces as far as
mexico was concerned taylor's troops
were invading their country and they had
no choice but to defend it despite
polk's war message saying that american
blood had been shed on american soil
many u.s politicians were also skeptical
about who started the war and where a
young whig congressman from illinois
named abraham lincoln demanded that polk
show him the exact spot where american
blood had been shed the war that ensued
was longer costlier and deadlier than
the u.s government had estimated which
is often the case with wars at its
conclusion polk had achieved his vision
for manifest destiny in the treaty of
guadalupe hidalgo which ended the war
the united states agreed to paying
mexico 15 million dollars and in
exchange mexico ceded texas california
and most of the modern day southwest to
the united states so what were the
effects of this war well the addition of
this mexican session territory had
far-reaching consequences for both the
united states and the residents of the
west the existing residents of the
territory including mexicans native
americans and the descendants of spanish
colonists found that life under the rule
of the united states could be very
different than under the rule of mexico
where mexican law had abolished slavery
and prescribed equality under the law
for people regardless of color the texas
constitution permitted slavery and
denied civil rights to non-white
residents for other residents of the
territory life didn't change much at all
huge suaves of the west were actually
controlled by native american nations
like the comanche empire which didn't
care whether the distant government who
claimed their territory on paper was
located in mexico city or in washington
dc for the united states government the
addition of this new territory was
political kryptonite both northerners
and southerners were convinced that the
opposite region was conspiring to limit
their economic opportunities in the west
during the war congressman david wilmot
of pennsylvania introduced a resolution
in the house that would prohibit slavery
in any territory gained from the
conflict the reaction to the wilmot
proviso showed just how big the
sectional divide in the country was
becoming since party lines broke down
entirely northerners whig and democrat
alike voted for the wilmot proviso and
southerners whig and democrat alike
voted against it ultimately the proviso
passed in the house but was defeated in
the senate and then gold was discovered
in california just before the end of the
war sending hordes of prospectors west
and making statehood for california an
urgent issue that would soon upset the
balance of power between free and slave
states in congress in other words we can
draw a direct line from the mexican war
to the breakdown of the second party
system which was replaced by a solidly
southern democratic party and a new
northern republican party and from there
to the civil war